[Musik]
selbst auf der leiter wird noch
widerstand geleistet
die polizei hat heute in den frühen
morgenstunden mit der räumung der liebig
34 angefangen das besetzte haus in
berlin friedrichshain gilt als symbol
objekt der linksradikalen szene bereits
in der nacht hatten hunderte
demonstranten gegen die räumung
protestiert zahlreiche autos wurden in
der umgebung in brand gesetzt
es kam vereinzelt zu
auseinandersetzungen zwischen polizei
und demonstranten
morgens um sieben dann der beginn der
räumung die polizei ist mit beamten aus
acht bundesländern im einsatz
im haus sollen sich an die 40 personen
befinden einen räumpanzer steht direkt
vor der eingangstür
doch weder der gerichtsvollzieher noch
die polizei gelangen in das
verbarrikadierte gebäude über ein gerüst
entern beamten den balkon im ersten
stock wer eine schnelle stürmung des
objekts erwartet liegt falsch und
richtig anlegen westliche staaten
kolleginnen und kollegen arbeiten
sie sehen mit kettensäge trennschleifer
und ähnlichem
um diese hindernisse liga eingerichtet
und zu überwinden
und genau das dauert natürlich dass die
zeit in anspruch gegen 8 uhr geben dann
die ersten bewohner auf über eine leiter
an balkon lassen sie sich abführen
einige recken die siegerfaust lassen
sich feiern während polizisten im innern
des hauses barrikaden entfernen werden
immer weitere hausbesetzer abgeführt
doch der widerstand auch außerhalb der
liebig 34 ist noch lange nicht vorbei
insgesamt haben wir so rundherum um die
hebelstraße auf dem 30 an
unterschiedlichen punkten gute 1500
menschen zusammengekommen sind
manche davon laut stark emotionalisiert
manche er geweiht bereit es gab auch
einzelne flasche sucht schon auf
einsatzkräfte
und ganz vereinzelt besonders bedenklich
an den demonstrationen in der umgebung
sollen auch grundschüler teilnehmen
die freie schule kreuzberg hatte in
einer mitteilung zur solidarität von
schülern und deren eltern aufgerufen
die polizei rechnet mit randalen und
ausschreitungen bis in die kommende
woche
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren